[Music]
Sarah Jessica Parker's new side bangs
make their red carpet debut their new
and becoming accustomed Sarah and the
rest of her divorce cast celebrated the
show's second season at the Paley Center
in New York City on Thursday night but
many fans are still holding out hope for
that third Sex in the City movie one
without Kim Cattrall who said she's done
with the franchise we've not had that
specific conversation but I mean I think
everybody's inclined to consider it we
all feel enormous ly lucky to have had
the experience we had you know together
camp Kristensen and myself and that's
extremely meaningful to us whether we
get to tell another chapter of that
story
I don't know if they despite an alleged
feud between the former co-stars Sarah
didn't let that get in the way of
sending Kim love and condolences after
her brother was found dead on Sunday
somebody in your life
whether you're in touch with them all
the time or not and they are suffering
for any reason
it's it's it's it's involuntary that you
want to convey condolences or sadness or
just let someone know that you're
thinking about them
[Music]